hi everyone my name's Tara chambers and
this is Tamara Jessa I went and saw a
hit man's bodyguard
solo today Cody is doing comedy in
another state so I went to the hit man's
bodyguard which is about a hitman who
needs a bodyguard all right we're done
here it was fine guys it was never funny
moments it had good action the
cinematography was pretty it looked good
the script through the weeks it felt
like any other kind of action film that
I've ever seen Ryan Reynolds has a
really great sense of joking for
Deadpool it really works for that
character to always be on and always be
joking and I think that's why he's just
perfect as Deadpool it doesn't work for
every other character that he's going to
play and it was it it was a similar vibe
the character was written as kind of
like this uptight kind of like by the
books guy but then with Ryan Reynolds
like always throwing in his kind of joke
style it felt just kind of like like
funny good moments but also super
clashing against what the character is
supposed to be samuel l.jackson was
amazing this role was written
specifically for him he was very funny
his comedy made sense in the role it
just didn't work for me with Ryan
Reynolds with his comedy style again he
was very funny in it just the character
wasn't supposed to be that way
I don't know how to say her name Salma
Hayek Salma Hayek also played Samuel
Jackson's wife and she was so funny this
is my favorite movie I've seen her in I
don't know that I've seen her in much
but she really hit the character just
very well she was written really funny I
was like the story on the whole it was
it was a cute story I feel like I've
seen it before
the biggest disappointment story wise
though was the love story between Ryan
Reynolds and his ex-wife or ex-fiance I
guess spoilers I don't know it's not
like you know a Harry Potter movie where
it's going to ruin everything for you
this is just what happens in the film
he Ryan Reynolds character gets upset at
his ex-wife because he messes up this
job and he thinks she's the one who kind
of told him out on the job and ended up
being Samuel Jackson which is very like
of course but he blamed her so much for
something that she didn't do that they
have to separate and then halfway
through the movie he decides to forgive
her which doesn't go well obviously then
at the end he finally like fully says
I'm sorry for it then they get back
together immediately and it just feels
very black like they don't have any
chemistry like in Deadpool the the lady
he was with in Deadpool I don't know
anyone named but they had such good
chemistry together that it just felt so
good and perfect and real this just was
like I don't care about you guys as a
couple it also doesn't really matter to
me if you get together again you know
enemies a harsh a little harsh sorry
like I said though I really enjoyed
samuel l.jackson Spartan this he had
some great lines I am harm's way
I am harm's way Sam I'm harm's way
Daniel L Jackson also sings in the film
a couple times and at one point it's
really touching as he's doing it for his
wife another part is he's doing it to
annoy Ryan Reynolds character and again
another character thing with Ryan
Reynolds Ryan Reynolds starts singing
and it's just very out of because he's
sitting there mad that he's singing like
he wants to keep quiet and everything
orderly but then to annoy samuel
l.jackson starts loudly singing it just
doesn't feel like something that is
character ado and if somebody else was
playing it maybe could have pulled it
off but Ryan Reynolds is such a funny
trying to be funny which normally
usually does well with but this was just
it felt like I was watching Ryan
Reynolds play Deadpool play this kind of
tight-ass bodyguard he was weird the
character of samuel l.jackson is driven
by the love of his wife and just really
sweet but it just comes down to that the
whole movie really for him his
motivation is is the love of his wife to
where one point he risks his life in the
whole mission just to put some flowers
in a
and his point where she'll see from her
jail cell she's in jail as well and at
the beginning they're like we'll pardon
your wife if you help us with this
mission and he's like oh you'll pardon
my wife who had done nothing wrong
that's some white it's necessarily
funny he calls people out in a good way
he's really tough but it just it comes
down to love for him just why were Ryan
Reynolds and it was like why is it
always love with you he's like well what
else is there it's really good and I
just did the difference of how I loved
these characters is so crazy I really
really loved Samuel Jackson and Ryan
Reynolds I take it or leave it it's
weird because I think if it would have
been another person cast other than Ryan
Reynolds I don't think the movie would
have done as well I think they had good
chemistry together Ryan Reynolds and
samuel l.jackson especially towards the
end but there were just weird joke
moments that just didn't work there's
kind of like that's not what your
character would do Deadpool look great
but just be something else you need to
get simon pegg in here he'll show us a
different character also the main bad
guy is pretty forgettable as well
I really wasn't invested at all in that
portion of the story just felt like like
I said before just like any other action
film but I've ever seen really it's
about these two men having to work
together when one of them is trying to
kill the other like 2720 times it's more
about that and then you get this side
story of the love and the love and you
get the side side story of like the
Eagle bad guys and so in that respect
it's fine it works because they have
good chemistry together but the main leg
chunk of like the where the action comes
from and like why they're doing this for
this like rid the world of this bad guy
just is boring I don't care that much so
the one part where Verizon and Reynolds
is like I forgive you to his ex-fiancee
for something that she didn't do samuel
l.jackson is like how did that go buddy
women don't like to be forgiven for
something because it implies they did
something wrong and like seven guys like
me
cave-like Hilton like low bro chuckling
uh-oh
like enuresis I mean it's true really
cool setting though in Amsterdam they
really used like the Canal waves in the
waterways and it was really exciting
I've also been there so that was cool I
know this place like when I get a movie
reference that I used to not get I just
kept comparing it to Deadpool muffled
sigh while watching it Ryan Reynolds I
really haven't seen him in anything
other than Deadpool this and then like
some romantic comedies I think I didn't
see green lantern think Cody and I are
going to do a Tamra's never seen a green
lantern soon think I really enjoyed some
of the acting in the movie the chemistry
between samuel l.jackson and Salma Hayek
and then samuel l.jackson and Ryan
Reynolds really worked I didn't find the
chemistry between Ryan and his ex-wife
to work very well but I liked her in the
film how the story was very black like
it's fun it's it's an action movie it's
pretty
there are definitely funny moments this
is a movie that you have to see in
theaters I don't think is I think you
could probably I could watch this at
home I think I would have enjoyed it
more I liked Ryan Reynolds in this I
just his charm that he puts on didn't
really work for me in this versus where
it sho works in Deadpool and I think I'm
being a little harsh on him as well he's
I enjoy him on screen but I don't know
for some reason it just didn't connect
with me in this one and that's okay I'm
fine
things happen oh it's got a thirty five
percent on Rotten Tomatoes okay okay
that's good to see I was worried I was
going a little harsh on it it's okay
it's an OK film like I said watch it at
home I don't think you need to go out to
the theaters to see this one the best
part of it is watching samuel l.jackson
who really hits his character well kind
of interact with other people in the
film there's some really funny things
with authority figures that he kind of
clashes husband
and it's really good I really enjoyed
him in this next week I'm also going to
be solo and I have no idea what to watch
there's not many movies coming out next
week let me know in the comments if you
think that I should visit something that
I missed valerian or or listen Valkyrie
Dunkirk what I meant and let me know
what you want to see next week regarding
Tamra's just saw also Tamra's never seen
I need help on all fronts everyone check
out my Twitter I put pulls up for series
like Tamra's just saw on camera nervous
I just had Tamra's just saw camera never
see Tara just saw and cameras ever seen
camera camera camera so much thanks for
stopping by see y'all next week bye
[Music]